Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer ganz besonderen Folge des Chaos Radio, zur Folge 300.
Und dafür haben wir uns ausgedacht, dass wir nicht in die schrecklichen Abgründe
der Digitalpolitik schauen und auch nicht gucken,
welche Technologie oder welche Ausprägung von Technologie schon wieder so kaputt
ist, dass man eigentlich alles anzünden muss, sondern wir haben uns vorgenommen,
hinter die Kulissen zu gucken.
Und zwar nicht nur hinter eine Kulisse, sondern eigentlich hinter ganz viele.
Zum Beispiel hinter die Kulissen des Chaos Communication Kongress oder anderer
Chaos Veranstaltungen.
Zum Beispiel auch so ein bisschen hinter die Kulissen dessen,
was der CCC eigentlich ist und wie der organisiert ist, wenn man davon Organisationen sprechen kann.
Und auch so ein bisschen hinter die Kulissen des Chaos-Radios eigentlich.
Wir wollen nämlich heute über eines der Dinge sprechen,
das eine drei Buchstaben Abkürzung hat. Es gibt ja also gerade,
wenn man im Chaos-Communication-Kongress CCC unterwegs ist,
gibt es ja das LOG und das POG und das NOG und das VOG.
Und darüber sprechen wir heute, über das Video Operations Center.
Und dazu bin ich nicht alleine.
Ich bin Markus Richter, ich versuche hier die Stränge ein bisschen in der Hand zu halten.
Und bei mir sind heute Sophie, hallo.
Hallo.
Jenny, auch bekannt als die Scientress, hallo.
Hi.
Und Danimo, den ihr vielleicht schon kennt, wenn ihr das Chaos Radio nicht erst seit heute hört. Hallo.
Moin.
Und ihr seid alle vom Video Operations Center.
Und ich will heute so ein bisschen hin und her springen, weil ich will erstmal
sozusagen das eine offensichtliche fragen,
weil man, wenn man euren Namen kennt, also wenn man das schon mal gehört hat,
dann hat man das wahrscheinlich im Zusammenhang mit dem Kongress gehört oder
im Zusammenhang einer der anderen Chaosveranstaltungen,
jetzt gerade war die Gulasch-Programmiernacht und da gibt es Video-Streaming
und da gibt es Videos und dann kann man wissen, die werden vom VOG gemacht.
Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, was ist das WOC eigentlich?
Also ist das eine Firma, die das dann spendet? Sind das jedes Mal andere Leute,
die ihre Handys irgendwo draufhalten?
Ist es eine Arbeitsgruppe, wie in der Wikipedia steht, was auch immer das sein
soll? Also was ist das WOC eigentlich?
Arbeitsgruppe trifft es vielleicht am besten.
Das WOC ist so eine lose bis halbfeste Sammlung an Veranstaltungstechnik-Nerds, Software-Devs,
Sys-Admins und noch ein paar andere Menschen drumherum, die sich hauptsächlich
auf Chaos-Veranstaltungen und chaosnahen Veranstaltungen trifft.
Und dort die Vorträge aufzeichnet und manchmal auch ein paar Videos drumherum produziert.
Okay, das hat ja so zwei spannende Ebenen. Das eine ist sozusagen,
womit macht man das, also wie ist die Technik organisiert und das andere ist dann die Organisation.
Wenn ihr sagt, wir zeichnen da die Vorträge auf,
wie viel Equipment bringt ihr da mit oder nutzt ihr sozusagen,
also der Chaoscom Communication Congress ist ja zum Beispiel jetzt wieder im
Kongresszentrum in Hamburg, die haben probably selber Technik,
Wie bringt ihr selber Sachen mit?
Womit zeichnet ihr auf? Was heißt aufzeichnen? Was heißt Streaming?
Warum müssen wir mal anfangen? Erstmal was von Technik mitbringen oder?
Aha, ich nehme mit, ihr bringt Technik mit. Genau, welche?
Kameras, Kabel, Computer, Encoder, Audio-Mischer, ganz viele Adapter,
um alle möglichen Probleme zu lösen.
Es gibt eine riesengroße Liste, auf der ungefähr 200 Items draufstehen pro Saal,
die unser Standard-Setup ausmachen.
Das ist klassischerweise in einem Flightcase und auch ein paar Zusatzkisten verpackt.
Wir sind aber dabei, das alles zu modernisieren, dass das nur noch zwei einheitliche
Flight Cases pro Raum sind fürs normale Standard Setup.
Der Kongress ist wieder ein bisschen Spezialfall, da ist meistens noch deutlich mehr unterwegs.
Sophie, du hast das wichtigste Item vergessen bei einer Aufzählung,
was wir mitbringen. Und zwar die Winkelkatze.
Oh stimmt, das ist natürlich sozusagen die erste Anekdote, von denen wir heute
vielleicht auch einige erleben, wenn die ihr erzählen müsst.
Es gibt die Winkelkatze traditionell, also gerade wenn nichts passiert, ist die immer im Bild.
Könnt ihr nochmal kurz den Nicht-Eingeweihten erklären, warum es eine Winkelkatze gibt?
Also, es begab sich zu der Zeit, als das WOC mit seinen Tätigkeiten begann.
Wir erinnern uns, damals war USB für die Datenübertragung so ein bisschen blöd
und die Profis haben Firewire hergenommen, zumindest im Home-Bereich.
Und wir haben also so aufgezeichnet, dass wir die Daten dann über Firewire aus
der Kamera in die Rechner bekamen.
Und jetzt gab es so einen blöden Bug im Linux-Körnel, dass manchmal einfach ein Frame stehen blieb.
Und wenn man so einen Vortragssaal hat, der leer ist, dann bewegt sich da wenig.
Und dass ein Vortrag anfängt, aber leider der Rechner hängen geblieben ist,
das erfährt man fünf Minuten nach dem Vortrag.
Das war ein bisschen ungünstig. Und deswegen haben wir nach einer Lösung gesucht,
das möglichst schnell zu erkennen.
Und die Low-Tech-Lösung war tatsächlich einfach, in jedes Flightcase eine Winkelkatze
reinzuschmeißen, die man vorne beim Redner aufs Pult schmeißt.
Und wenn die nicht mehr winkt, gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten.
Die Batterie ist leer oder der Frame-Buffer ist wieder stehen geblieben.
Und so ist die Winkelkatze entstanden.
Auch nachdem dieses Problem mit dem Frame-Buffer längst gelöst war und wir schon
lange keinen Firewire mehr machen.
Jetzt ist das sozusagen euer Maskottchen, muss immer dabei sein.
Jetzt ist das irgendwie unser Maskottchen geworden.
So, ich möchte aber zurück zu der Aussage kommen, dass ihr pro Saal eine Packliste
mit ungefähr 200 Dingen habt.
War das jetzt eine dramaturgische Übertreibung oder sind das literally grob 200 Dinge?
Wir haben ein Inventarsystem, das Wink, und da sind, glaube ich,
wirklich knapp 200 Items pro Saal drinne.
Ich bin jetzt sozusagen sofort hin und her gerissen, in welche Richtung man abbiegt.
Aber das eine, was ich mich frage, ist eine so Arbeitsgruppe kann ja ein sehr
schwammiges Wort sein. Wenn in Festangestellten Bürojobs eine Arbeitsgruppe
gegründet wird, dann ist das ja eher sozusagen ein Grund, die Hände im Kopf
zusammenzuschlagen, weil nicht viel passiert.
Wenn jetzt auf Veranstaltungen für jeden Saal Dinge, die eine Inventarliste
von 200 haben, nicht nur da sind, sondern auch auf, abgebaut und betrieben werden
müssen, dann muss das ja irgendwie organisiert werden.
Und davor frage ich immer noch, wo kommt das her? Also ich meine,
wenn man eine Handvoll Streams hat und jeder Streams hat so eine riesige Hardware,
da guckt jeder Nerd in seine Kabelkiste und in seinen,
hier liegen die Geräte, die ich mal gekauft habe, aber bin nicht mehr im Nutzerraum
rum und dann wirft man das alles zusammen? Oder woher kommt das ganze Equipment?
Der Großteil der Technik gehört der CCCV, also der Chaos Computer Club Veranstaltungsgesellschaft,
der vor vielen Jahren inzwischen,
Anfang 2013 war das glaube ich, ein Projektantrag gestellt wurde für die Anschaffung
von Technik für die Aufzeichnung von vier parallelen Tracks.
So steht es im CCC-Wiki.
Diese CCCV hat diese Technik gekauft und dem Video Operation Center zur Verwaltung überlassen.
Das Video Operation Center an sich ist eigentlich gar keine eigene Legal Entity,
kein Verein, kein gar nichts.
Es ist nur ein Haufen Nerds, die die Technik selbst verwaltet,
betreiben, nenne ich es jetzt mal.
Okay, ich will tatsächlich so sagen, über die Frage, wie arbeitet ihr zusammen,
will ich auch gleich kommen, aber vielleicht können wir kurz über die Technik sprechen.
Und jetzt habe ich ja probably das Problem, wenn sich da so Leute zusammenschließen,
die daran arbeiten, dass sie sehr begeistert von der Technik sind.
Und ich würde, also können wir vielleicht so eine Balance finden,
nicht jedes Jahr 200 Dinge sozusagen einzeln zu besprechen, was bestimmt faszinierend ist.
Das will ich nicht abstreiten, aber könntet ihr uns eine grobe Idee davon geben,
sozusagen welcher, also technischer Standard klingt jetzt wieder so hart,
aber sozusagen auf welchem Level sich dieses Equipment befindet.
Also ist das eine Entsprechung von eigentlich habt ihr da ein mobiles Fernsehstudio
oder ist das, also wie man es aus dem Podcast-Bereich kennt,
da kauft man sich Technik, die ist so ein bisschen teurer, da ist man so als
Semi-Profi oder High-Level-Amateur unterwegs,
und hat dann so Krams, das klingt schon gut, aber es gibt dann trotzdem eine Stufe.
Könnt ihr das so ein bisschen einordnen, was ihr da habt und auf welcher Qualitätsebene das stattfindet?
Also wir haben da so ein bisschen ein Mischmasch, sag ich mal.
Wir haben, die Kameras sind so im unteren Profi-Segment unterwegs,
auch weil wir halt zum Übertragen auf langen Strecken SDI nutzen,
was jetzt ein Broadcast-Video-Standard ist,
weil HDMI tut nicht so gern über 5 Meter.
Und danach haben wir aber nicht so einen klassischen Broadcast-Media-Mischer,
wie man jetzt kennt von Blackmagic oder Co.,
sondern wir haben eine eigene geschriebene Software, die optimiert ist auf unsere Anforderungen,
auf die Aufzeichnungen, Vorträgen und auf möglichst einfache Bedienbarkeit,
weil wir ja in den Seelen von den fleißigen Ängeln unterstützt werden,
die dann am Schluss die Kameras und auch der Videomischer bedienen.
Und in dieser Software Walk2Mix, die ja auch Open Source ist natürlich, haben wir halt
reingearbeitet, wie es sich ein Workflow ergeben hat, weil früher haben wir
auch bei den Kongressen so Hardware-Videomischer benutzt,
wie halt Computer noch nicht so leistungsstark waren, dass das mit relativ einfacher
Hardware machbar ist und daraus hat sich halt ergeben,
was wir halt haben wollen und zum Beispiel, was Walk2Mix halt alles gut kann,
ist halt automatisiert aufzeichnen, einerseits das gemischte Bild,
andererseits immer die Slides aufzeichnen,
sodass man immer beim Vortrag auch immer die Slides sehen kann.
Das heißt, in fertigen Videos gibt es halt nicht nur die normale Videospur,
sondern es gibt eine zweite Videospur in allen Files, wo man halt die Slides immer sehen kann.
Und wenn man das jetzt abbilden würde mit normaler Profi-Hardware,
wäre das relativ kompliziert.
Und mit Walk2Mix geht es sehr einfach.
Wir haben uns eigentlich auch bei der Gründung des Vox so ein bisschen auf die Fahnen geschrieben,
so ein bisschen zu entscheiden, was lässt sich mit Hardware gut machen,
was ist besser in Software abgebildet und vor allen Dingen war auch immer so
ein bisschen die Idee, wenn sich jemand von unseren Setups inspirieren lassen
will, soll das für die Leute auch machbar sein.
Also man muss jetzt nicht auf Teufel komm raus ein SDI-Setup haben,
man muss nicht auf Teufel komm raus die tollsten Kameras haben,
man kann trotzdem für Konferenzen Vokto-Mix einsetzen.
Also die Idee ist, für uns soll es convenient sein, aber auch für Dritte irgendwie nützlich.
Also verstehe ich das richtig. Also einerseits baut ihr oder habt ihr euch ein Setup zusammengebaut,
was auf unteren professionellen Level sozusagen so, also in der Kombination
von Hard- und Software sozusagen ein unteres professionelles Level-Bild generiert,
also vergleichbar mit einem, keine Ahnung,
Hochleistungs-YouTuberInnen oder StreamerInnen oder sowas oder vielleicht auch
irgendwie kleine Fernsehübertragung.
Und andererseits ist das Ziel aber auch, dass eine Software entsteht,
die so oder entstanden ist, die so leistungsfähig ist, dass man die mit Hardware
verschiedener Qualität betreiben kann, sodass man das als Beispiel nehmen kann.
Okay, das heißt, die Hardware habt ihr sozusagen gekauft, ihr habt mit dem Geld,
was ihr bekommen habt, das wahrscheinlich Bestmögliche euch geholt und dann
sozusagen mit der Software zu.
Genau, wobei man sagen muss, die Kameras, die wir jetzt aktuell benutzt haben,
sind in die Jahre gekommen und das sieht man halt auch noch in ihrem Bild,
weil da hat sich halt in den letzten zehn Jahren sehr viel weiterentwickelt,
aber jetzt haben wir ja gerade neue Kameras gekauft und die sind jetzt dann
bei den nächsten Events im Einsatz, bei der GPN noch nicht, da haben wir nur eine gehabt,
aber bei den kommenden Events,
sobald die neuen Flightcats fertig sind, haben wir ganz neue Kameras.
Und das wird sich dann auch im Bild zeigen.
Vielleicht ist das dann der eine Punkt, wo ihr ein kleines bisschen ins Detail gehen könntet.
Wenn man heutzutage sozusagen überlegt, ich möchte eine Kamera für Bewegtbild, die mir einen,
Die mir halt ein semiprofessionelles Bild macht. In welcher,
also A, was kauft man dann?
Also ist das, kauft man dann, also ich habe zum Beispiel eine Spiegelreflexkamera,
die ich als Videoeingabetool für meine Streams benutze.
Was, wie ich finde, sehr gut aussieht, aber vielleicht ist es auch totaler Quatsch
und es ist auch schon sehr alt.
Aber vielleicht könnt ihr da so ein bisschen ins Hintergrund gehen.
In welcher Liga ist man unterwegs und welche Art von Gerät?
Also kauft man dann schon quasi kleine Fernsehkameras oder nutzt man Consumer-Hardware,
die irgendwie in so einer Mid-High-Level-Price-Range ist?
Kommt ganz darauf an, was man erreichen will.
Was ihr erreichen wolltet. Danimo hat ja gesagt, man soll es verschieden gehen.
Mit dem, was ihr macht, wofür habt ihr euch entschieden? In welcher Kategorie ist man da unterwegs?
Wir haben uns jetzt für eine Kamera entschieden, wo zum einen das SDI geht, was Jenny erwähnt hat.
Dann ist es wichtig, dass wir tonprofessionell da direkt reinbekommen aus einem Mischpult.
Das macht man dann üblicherweise nicht mehr über so einen ollen Klinkenstecker,
sondern über symmetrisches XLR.
Eine andere Sache ist, wir müssen unsere Kameras ja so aufbauen,
dass wir nicht im Weg sind.
Das heißt, wir sind sehr weit weg von den eigentlichen Rednern,
sehr weit weg von der Bühne.
Das heißt, wir brauchen auch eine Kamera mit einem guten Zoom und eine Kamera,
die dann auch immer noch lichtstark ist, wenn man sehr stark reinzoomt.
Wenn man jetzt die Möglichkeit hat, das für sich mitzuschneiden und irgendwie
einen Ton separat aufnimmt, dann kann man das auch prima mit dem iPhone machen.
Das ist immer das, was uns gerade nimmt. Warum macht er das nicht mit einem iPhone?
Genau deswegen, wenn man das zeitsouverän produzieren kann, den Ton separat
aufnimmt und einfach nur irgendwas auf ein Stativ stellt, dann kann man seinen
Vortrag auch sehr gut mit einem iPhone aufzeichnen, nur dann muss man später
die Slides reinschneiden und so weiter und so fort.
Das heißt, wir brauchen eine lineare Produktion und wir müssen halt die Kameras
möglichst, also nicht immer optimal aufstellen, sodass wir halt auf diesen Zoom angewiesen sind.
Und das lässt einen recht schnell bei den teuren Kameras im Semipro beziehungsweise
in den günstigeren Kameras im Profisegment landen.
Ein üblicher Kongresstag geht von morgens um 10 bis nachts um 3.
Solange müssen die Kameras durchgängig durchhalten und auch aufzeichnen können ihr internes Backup.
Und da sind DSLRs häufig auf die üblichen 30 Minuten und dann bin ich zu warm beschränkt.
So Prosumer, Camcorder, wie wir es hier einsetzen, haben kein Problem auch mal
5 Tage am Stück durchzulaufen. Deren Sensoren sind auch dafür gebaut.
Könnt ihr mal eine Price Range oder eine Hausnummer sagen?
Ihr habt jetzt gerade nachgeguckt, also der Listenpreis für unsere neue Kamera wäre 4.400 Euro.
Okay, krass.
Das ist natürlich nicht, dass es am Ende zahlt, dass solche Hardware.
Die Listenpreise sind da fernab von der Realität. Ich glaube nicht,
dass wir jetzt den finalen Preis erwähnen dürfen, den wir gekriegt haben,
aber ja, das ist eine Sony PXW Z200, die wir jetzt gekauft haben, sechs Stück von.
Und die ist halt eben so im unteren Segment jetzt vom Profikamera-Bereich,
von so kleineren Camcorders.
Und was eben so viel so schon erlebt hat, DSLRs machen auch ein super Bild,
teilweise ein besseres Bild, aber für so durchgängig Aufnehmen oder Live-Produktionen
sind die halt nicht gebaut.
Also einerseits sind die Stecker schon ganz anders ausgelegt.
Wenn es so eine DSLR bei uns reinlegen
würde, es wären die Anschlüsse vermutlich nach einem Jahr kaputt.
Okay, jetzt hat man sozusagen ein Gefühl dafür, worum es geht.
Vielleicht noch grad sagen, also XLR ist ein Audio-Standard,
wo man so dickere Kabel hat, die drei Kontakte haben.
Falls ihr schon mal ein Mikrofon in der Hand hattet, also im Bühnenmikrofon,
dann hat er das wahrscheinlich die Anschlusslinie gesehen.
SDI, wie ich es richtig verstanden habe, ist auch eine Art und Weise,
über Kabel Daten zu übertragen, die eben vor allen Dingen dafür gemacht ist,
dass Bilddaten gut übertragen werden. Das ist richtig?
Genau, also das ist so, SDI ist halt ein Broadcast-Video-Standard.
Das steht für Serial Digital Interface.
Und das wurde entwickelt anfangs, um SD-Bildsignale digital zu übertragen.
Mittlerweile geht es bis 8K hoch, Zimmer hoch übertragen kann damit,
was dann über ein Coax-Kabel läuft, bei 8K 12 Gigabit pro Sekunde.
Wir benutzen es mit 3 Gigabit pro Sekunde. Das lässt sich bis,
also bei 3 Gigabit kann man gute 80 Meter über so ein Kabel fahren.
Ohne Signalverstärkung. Aber man kann auch längere Strecken fahren,
weil es gibt auch STI über Fiber. Dann hat man Kilometer.
Und bei den Quarks-Kabeln ist
halt auch noch wichtig, die haben einen ordentlichen Bayonettverschluss.
Da ist nicht, wenn man mal kurz drüber stolpert, auf einmal das Kabel draußen
oder so. Also das ist halt auch, was die Robustheit angeht, nochmal ein ganz
anderes Level als bei HDMI.
Also ich finde es interessant, weil man über das, was man lernt,
man kennt jetzt nicht euer Setup, aber man lernt schon so verschiedene Dinge, nämlich zum Beispiel,
es reicht eben nicht, dass das Gerät ein gutes Bild macht oder sozusagen auch
die Hardware einfach da ist, sondern die muss halt auch stabil sein und zwar sowohl im Sinne von,
die muss halt mal durchlaufen lange und auch, es ist halt eine Veranstaltung,
wo Menschen sind und Menschen tendieren dazu, in Dinge reinzufallen und dann
darf das halt nicht sozusagen, wenn man es anguckt, gleich auseinanderfallen.
Aber das Spannendste finde ich eigentlich, das ist ja gerade,
wenn man im Digitalen ist, gibt es ja immer so dieses Ding, naja,
wir machen das und dann werfen wir es halt irgendwie zusammen.
Aber wenn ich es richtig verstehe, ist ein großer Teil des Fokus auch eine lineare
Produktion war sozusagen die Wortkette, die Danimo gerade gesagt hat,
aber sozusagen ein sehr klassisches.
Wir müssen das von Anfang an so gut wie möglich machen, weil ansonsten wird
es eben entweder im Nachhinein sehr viel Aufwand oder ist auch im Stream kein
zufriedenstellendes Ergebnis. Also das heißt...
Das ist ein Teil schon klassische Bewegtbild-TV-Produktion, könnte man sagen, was ihr macht, oder?
Ganz genau. Also die Ergebnisse dessen, was man so auf YouTube sieht,
ist ja sehr oft, jemand redet in eine Kamera und jemand anderes,
den man eigentlich nie zu Gesicht bekommt, verwendet sehr, sehr viel Zeit darauf,
das dann hübsch aussehen zu lassen, Grafikelemente einzublenden und so weiter.
Während klassisches Fernsehen ja wirklich eine Regie hat, wo jemand sitzt und
die einzelnen Elemente zusammenfährt, sodass man dann also ein Echtzeitbild
hat, was dann angeguckt werden kann.
Und wir befinden uns in so einer interessanten Zwischenwelt,
wo wir eigentlich diese klassische Fernsehdenker haben.
Wir produzieren also in Echtzeit, das heißt im Saal sitzt jemand,
der dieses Vokto-Mix bedient und entscheidet, was ist jetzt wichtiger,
die Slides anzuzeigen, die Leute auf der Bühne anzuzeigen oder eine Mischung
aus beidem. Das sind halt voreingestellte Szenen.
Wir haben Menschen, die die Kameras bedienen, den Leuten folgen,
eventuell sogar bei etwas höherwertigen Produktionen dann mit einer Schulterkamera
oder so auf der Bühne stehen und dann ranzoomen an irgendwelche kleinen Elektronikbauteile,
die es da gerade zu zeigen gibt.
Das Ganze funktioniert eben nicht im Nachhinein.
Die Zeit, die wir zur Verfügung haben, ist eigentlich beschränkt auf das Event
mit ganz wenigen Ausnahmen, wo wir dann zum Beispiel Technikpflege machen.
Das heißt, alles, was nicht auf dem Event passiert, passiert nicht mehr.
Das heißt wir müssen es schaffen das so hinzukriegen, dass auf dem Event die Produktion,
die Postproduktion und die Veröffentlichung passiert und das geht nur über extrem
starke Automatisierung von allen Dingen vielleicht wollen wir da nochmal drüber
reden wie das im Einzelnen funktioniert gleich
Aber ich würde gerne mal ich würde also sagen jetzt noch die andere Seite dieser
Medaille, weil ich habe ja am Anfang gesagt, das ist ja ein technisches Problem und das, also,
wenn ich mir die Geschichte der Menschheit angucke, würde es mich überraschen,
wenn das nicht auch ein Organisationsproblem ist.
Weil, also gerade auch, was du jetzt gesagt hast, könnte man sich ja vorstellen,
geil, es gibt also diese Technik, die hat mal irgendjemand zusammengestöpselt
und dann kommen die halt an und stellen die in den Saal und dann ist da halt
irgendwie fünf Tage lang Alarm und dann wird das wieder abgebaut.
Fertig. Mein Verdacht ist, das ist nicht ganz so einfach.
Es ist nicht ganz so ein. Es ist nicht ganz so einfach.
Die Technik will in der richtigen Reihenfolge zusammengesteckt werden.
Bald ist deutlich weniger zusammenzustecken im neuen Flightcase-Konzept.
Im alten Konzept tragen wir dann munter Mesh-Bags mit kleinen Adapterchen und
Kabeln und Steckern und Steckdosen.
Was sind Mesh-Bags?
Es sind so halbdurchsichtige PVC-Beutel, die mit einem Gewebe verstärkt sind
und einen Reißverschluss meistens farbig haben.
Gibt es in DIN A5, DIN A4 und größer. Das sind so kleine Taschen,
um Dinge drin zu verstauen.
Wir haben sie bisher verwendet, um zum Beispiel alle HDMI-Adapter zusammenzufassen
oder um zu einem Gerät auch gleichzeitig noch das Netzteil mit dazu zu packen.
Die tragen wir dann beim Aufbau munter durch die Gegend, ziehen uns die Tüten
aus dem Flightcase, die wir jetzt gerade brauchen, um alles an der Kamera aufzubauen
oder alles auf dem Rednerpult aufzubauen.
Verlegen dann, wenn die einzelnen Stationen im Saal fertig sind,
noch die langen Kabel dazwischen, stecken die an die Rechner und konfigurieren das Ganze.
Dabei sind dann zwei enge, meistens so eineinhalb bis zwei Stunden beschäftigt
und dann steht das Setup im Saal zumindest mal, wenn alles gut läuft.
Fang irgendwann die Vorträge an. Für jeden Vortrag braucht man auch wieder Leute,
die die Technik bedienen.
Warte mal, bevor wir zum Livebetrieb kommen, am Beispiel des Kongresses,
wie lange vorher passiert das?
Also weil theoretisch sozusagen, da sind Leute zwei Stunden beschäftigt,
könnte man ja auch zwei Stunden vor dem Opening machen.
Aber auch hier wird wahrscheinlich nicht so sein. Wie viele Tage vor so einer
Veranstaltung rechnet ihr?
Der Kongress ist ein Spezialfall.
Da ist klassischerweise Tag minus eins und Tag null sind die Tage,
wo das Wok in den Sälen aufbaut.
Also so ungefähr zwei Aufbautage, je nachdem wann Menschen ankommen und wann
wir in die Säle rein dürfen.
Auf kleineren Veranstaltungen, haben wir alles zwischen einem Tag und zwei Stunden Aufbauzeit.
Es gab auch schon ein Event, wo der LKW nachts um vier ankam und um neun vormittags
dann am selben Tag der erste Vortrag war.
Ja, wir versuchen das Setup so weit zu optimieren, dass es in kürzerer Zeit aufgebaut werden kann.
Praktisch dauert es aber, Meister, doch ein bisschen länger,
weil wir noch irgendwas suchen müssen, irgendwas nicht funktioniert,
irgendwo die Knicke aus dem Kabel raus müssen und die Bugs gefunden werden müssen.
Oder die Haustechnik streikt.
Oh ja.
Haustechnik meint immer sozusagen die technische Infrastruktur,
die vor Ort ist und Engel, um vielleicht noch mal kurz zu sagen,
sind halt nicht, ist nicht bestimmte Art von Menschen, die beim WOC mitarbeiten,
sondern das sind bei den chaosnahen Veranstaltungen Freiwillige, die sich erstmal,
also man kann das würde mich doch einschränken, aber sozusagen,
das ist erstmal nur eine Bezeichnung für freiwillig gesagt, aber wir helfen bei der Veranstaltung.
Daniel, du wolltest gerade noch was?
Genau. Wir haben einmal natürlich diese Aufbauzeit on-site.
Da gibt es also, wie gesagt, wenn wir jetzt nicht vom Kongress reden,
haben wir auch schon Events gehabt, wo wir drei Stunden vor Veranstaltungsbeginn
erst ins Gebäude konnten.
Das gibt es alles. Aber auch dann hat mindestens eine Begehung stattgefunden.
Also in der Regel machen wir das immer so, dass wir versuchen,
vorher mit den Leuten, die dort technikverantwortlich sind, in der Lokation
einmal da durchzugehen und zu sagen, okay, kriegen wir da genügend Strom,
kriegen wir da vielleicht noch Licht hin und so weiter,
sodass das dann hinterher geklärt ist für uns.
Und dann muss ja auch noch eine andere Sache stattfinden, nämlich das Zeug muss ja irgendwie dahin.
Ist das sozusagen, ihr schreibt in eine wie geartete Messenger-Gruppe,
wer hat gerade ein Auto und kann das da hinfahren?
Oder ist das auch generalstabsmäßiger organisiert?
Wir haben mittlerweile so alle Logistika mal durchgespielt.
Also das ist schon lange nicht mehr auf dem Niveau, dass man das mal irgendwo
in den Kofferraum räumt.
In der Regel werden Logistika dafür beauftragt.
Firmen oder andere Leute, die ähnlich wie das WOC im Chaosumfeld eine Arbeitsgruppe sind?
Wir haben das Log, das tatsächlich auch Leute macht, aber für die Mehrzahl der
Dinge sind es wirklich professionelle Logistikfirmen.
Okay.
Stellt sich dann raus, die haben alle sehr spezielle Vorstellungen davon,
wie die Verfügbarkeit von Menschen ist, die largely inkompatibel mit den Arbeitszeiten
von Nerds und unseren Veranstaltungen sind.
Und wenn man nicht peinlich genau aufpasst, dann werden auch schon mal Dinge
zerschenkert, wie wir gerne sagen.
Das ist deswegen ein Insider, weil Schenker sozusagen ein großes Logistikunternehmen in Deutschland ist.
Ich glaube, Sophie kann da ihren Großteil an Schmerz erzählen.
Ja, aufgrund verschiedenster Umstände ist das Lager der Videotechnik sehr nah
an meinem Wohn- und Arbeitsort.
Wir übernehmen hier den Großteil des Versands und der Lagerhaltung und Pflege
von der Technik und leider passiert es immer wieder,
dass Logistikunternehmen nicht wissen, was ein Flightcase ist und dass Rollen
unter Flightcases auch gut und gerne Bremsen haben könnten.
Und dass das doch keine Panzerplatten sind, aus denen diese Kisten gebaut sind.
Das waren doch nur Multiplex.
Das waren doch nur Multiplex Holzplatten. Und dann sind halt gerne mal irgendwelche
Alu-Verstärkungskanten abgerissen,
Nieten ausgerissen, Rollen kommen dann achteckig wieder zurück oder sind gleich
ganz ausgeknickt und haben die Kugeln ihres Kugellagers verloren.
Aber die Technik muss auf dem Transport einiges mitmachen.
Ich möchte, ich möchte es glaube nicht zu sehr in die Details gehen,
was wir mit welchem Versanddienstleister schon erlebt haben.
Also das steht nur Passportoto, das Zerschenkern. Da tun die sich alle nicht viel.
Ja.
Ich finde, jetzt fällt gerade auf, ein anderes Meta-Learning,
was man heute mitnehmen kann, ist manchmal wieder gefragt, der Kongress,
das Ticket kostet ja Geld, was passiert eigentlich mit dem ganzen Geld?
Zum Beispiel das hier. Ich finde es immer ganz spannend, weil ganz viel an dem
Club ist ja freiwilligen Arbeit, aber wir leben halt in einer Welt,
wo Dinge Geld kosten, zum Beispiel die Hardware.
Und manchmal ist es sozusagen eben auch sinnvoll, dass eben nicht freiwilligen
Arbeit dafür sorgt, dass Dinge irgendwo hingekarrt werden zum Beispiel.
Also das kann man vielleicht auch mitnehmen. Okay, das heißt also,
vorweg findet schon ganz viel statt.
Also jetzt zurück zur Veranstaltung, was ihr anhubt zu sagen.
Da sind ja dann auch eben eine Vielzahl von Menschen beschäftigt.
Wir haben mehrere Engeljobs auf jeder Veranstaltung.
Je nach Ausbau der Veranstaltung mal einen Ticken mehr, mal einen Ticken weniger.
Aber es gibt eigentlich mindestens immer die Engel, die an der Kamera stehen
und die Engel, die am Videomix sitzen.
Kameraengel führen die Kameras nach, sorgen dauerhaft für ein hübsches Bild,
was ordentlich ausgeleuchtet ist, hoffentlich in Fokus ist und die auf der Bühne
sprechenden Personen einfängt.
Videomixerengel.
Mischen das Bild, wählen aus den ihnen zufügend stehenden Bildern von ein bis
drei Kameras und den Slides aus.
Was jetzt gerade am wichtigsten ist, Slides mit viel kleinem Text in Fullscreen,
schöne Gesten auf der Bühne dann mit der Kamera oder auch einen sogenannten
Lecture-Mode mit Slides und Kamera-in-Porträt-Klein daneben.
Ich finde, ich möchte mal kurz fragen, weil ich finde, es gibt bei diesem ganzen
Konzept der freiwilligen Arbeit,
gibt es ja manchmal sozusagen eine Gratwanderung, die man treffen muss oder
beziehungsweise man muss sich manchmal für einen Trade-off entscheiden und das
eine ist ja, wir machen das alle freiwillig,
also die sind das eine Extrem sozusagen und jeder, der das will,
soll da eigentlich mitmachen können dürfen und das andere ist ja,
ihr habt wahrscheinlich so eine gewisse Erwartungshaltung, wir können gleich
noch über Publikumspressure sprechen.
Könnte man vielleicht, also es ist für mich vorspielt, dass man vielleicht auch
sagt, naja, das sollen eigentlich nur Leute machen, die wenigstens ein bisschen
Ahnung haben oder wo wir nach einem kurzen Check denken, die sind da irgendwie
fit oder lernen das schnell.
Wie macht ihr das?
Das WOC veranstaltet auf jedem Event eine Engelschulung.
Es war früher immer so eine Stunde Vortrag. Wir fallen jetzt seit einer Weile
schon ein bisschen am Konzept und das ist ein bisschen wenig weiter weg vom
drögen Vortrag oder nachher ein bisschen ausprobieren zu bekommen.
Aber es gibt eigentlich immer irgendwo eine Engelschulung. Entweder am Tag,
wo das Event beginnt oder am Vortag, je nachdem wie es so in den Fahrplan passt.
Wo wir das Wichtigste erzählen, ein paar grundlegende Regeln aufstellen und
versuchen näher zu bringen, die wichtigsten Kontrollelemente an der Kamera und am Mischer zu erklären.
Und danach funktioniert das eigentlich meistens ganz gut mit den freiwilligen HelferInnen.
Es gibt ein paar, die sind schon seit Ewigkeiten dabei und tauchen auf jedem Event wieder auf.
Es gibt auch jedes Mal wieder Leute, die das zum ersten Mal machen und direkt aufblühen.
Das heißt, also ganz platt gefragt, wenn jetzt jemand dieses Chaos gerade hört.
Und vielleicht bis jetzt die Vorstellung hat, das macht halt irgend so eine
Arkane-Entität, die in sich abgeschlossen ein elitärer Zirkel von Profis ist
und jetzt feststellt, wait a minute.
Nein, nein, nein.
Okay, man kann einfach beim nächsten Event, wo man selber ist und Engel ist,
kann man, wie auch immer, die Kanäle dann gestaltet und sagen,
so hier, ich würde gerne mitmachen, geht das.
Genau. Der Geheimtipp ist eigentlich genau das, was du gerade sagtest,
Markus, auf Events gehen und zwar vor allen Dingen auf kleine Events.
Weil je kleiner die Events, desto weniger Aufwand ist das meistens,
weil je mehr sind wir in unserem Standard-Setup in der Regel.
Und das heißt, da können wir uns dann auch eher mal Zeit nehmen,
nicht nur zu zeigen, wie hältst du die Kamera richtig und welche Szenen wählst
du optimalerweise bei der Bildauswahl,
sondern halt auch mal ein bisschen weiter die Technik erklären,
was wir so machen, vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen Leute schneiden lassen,
also in die Postproduktion reingehen lassen und so weiter und so fort.
Und das ist eigentlich so der Weg, wo man dann auch so ein bisschen in diesen,
wie es vielleicht von außen wahrgenommen wird und wie du es gerade so schön
karikiert hast, elitären Zirkel kommt, der es natürlich nicht ist.
Das ist kein elitärer Zirkel. Wenn da draußen jetzt Menschen zuhören und beim
VOG mitmachen wollen, kommt einfach auf ein Event, wo wir sind,
sprecht uns an, wir erklären gerne alles.
Wir sind kein elitärer Zirkel, wir sind offen, kommt dazu, guckt,
was wir tun, sucht euch aus, wo ihr mithelfen wollt und legt los.
Genau, ich erkläre das nur deswegen so, weil es erfahrungsgemäß immer die drei, vier Leute gibt,
die genau zum Kongress zu uns ins Backoffice kommen und dann gerne nochmal an
Positionen, die nicht Kameraengel und Mischer sind, direkt mitmachen wollen.
Und dann müssen wir ihnen immer erklären, dass wir ihnen zwar alles gerne erklären,
aber dass wir sie jetzt in der Form auf dem Kongress eher nicht einbinden können
und das wird leider auch manchmal falsch verstanden. Das ist nicht der Punkt.
Okay, also erstes Mal WOC-Management mitmachen wollen, vielleicht nicht auf
dem Kongress oder nirgendwo anders.
Ich glaube, wenn man dazu auch sagen muss, so ein Event geht für uns halt nicht
am Tag minus ist eins los und das Event geht für uns Monate vor dem Event los.
Gerade der Kongress, da fangen wir halt irgendwo im Spätsommer an mit der Planung.
Das heißt sozusagen, man soll sich eigentlich jetzt melden, wenn man lustig
ist und nicht erst auf dem Event. Was auch geht, habe ich wahrgenommen,
aber sozusagen, wenn man langfristig interessiert ist, vielleicht auch jetzt
einfach sofort sagen, man kann sich das nächste Mal irgendwo dazustoßen.
Es gibt ja auch auf unserer Webseite den Terminkalender für Meetings.
Steht in den Showrooms dann der Link?
Genau, da kann man auch dann sich mal schön einfach ein Meeting anschauen.
Okay, hier gibt es ein Kick-Off-Meeting für die Veranstaltung.
Das heißt, vielleicht, wenn man sich bei einer gewissen Veranstaltung interessiert
mitzumachen, kann man mal zu dem Kick-Off-Meeting dazukommen.
Und die andere Sache ist, wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit darüber gesprochen,
also wie das Live-Bild entsteht.
Und da steckt dann auch schon Technik hinter, Also diese Vokto-Mix-Software,
die ihr anscheinend auch programmiert.
Jetzt gibt es ja aber dahinter nochmal eine ganze Infrastruktur,
die eben dafür sorgen muss, dass ich das auf meinem Endgerät sehen kann.
Nämlich entweder während des Events für das Streaming oder nach dem Event als Video-on-Demand.
Macht ihr das auch oder gibt es dann ein SOC, ein Streaming-Operation-Center,
das das nochmal extra macht?
Gibt es eine Übergabe oder macht ihr das auch alleine?
Die Streaming-Webseite und das CDN ist auch quasi aus unserer Feder selbstgeschrieben bzw.
Open-Source-Software zusammengesteckt, sodass es für unsere Zwecke funktioniert.
Media-CCC.de wird von einem dedizierten Media-Team betrieben,
die Backend-Server dafür und das CDN.
Aber wir füttern vom Event aus da direkt unsere Videos rein.
CDN heißt Content Delivery Network und ist ganz einfach erklärt eine Ansammlung
von Computern, die dafür zuständig sind, dass man Videos abrufen kann.
Jenny, du wolltest auch gerade noch?
Ja, ne, so viel ist eh super erklärt, aber wenn ihr wollt, kann ich euch mal
erklären, wie quasi ein Video aus dem Saal nach Media wandert.
Okay.
Also, wir produzieren ja eben live-to-tape, wenn man es aus der TV-Welt würde
so bezeichnen, weil wir halt quasi den fertig geschnittenen Mix aufnehmen.
Und wenn so ein Talk vorbei ist, dann sitzen wir halt im Walk-Office,
die Leute im Walk-Office sitzen, fangen dann halt an mit dem Cutting-Prozess.
Das heißt, da wird eigentlich nur noch, hier hat der Talk angefangen,
hier ist der Talk vorbei gesetzt in den Videofiles.
Dafür haben wir eigens geschrieben, eine Software, einen Tracker und ganz viel Tooling drumherum.
Der wurde ungesprächig angefangen von der FEM, von der TU Ilmenau,
die früher, bevor das WOC gegründet wurde, oft die Aufzeichnung gemacht hat.
Und sobald der In- und Outpoint da gesetzt ist, läuft es dann ins Transcoding
und die fertigen Videofall wird berechnet.
Seitdem wir jetzt auch in AFA1. AFA1 ist ein Videostandard, ein offener,
neuer, der sehr starke Kompressierung hat aber auch sehr gute Bit-Qualität hat
und halt ein komplett Open-Source-Videostandard ist.
Das heißt, die Spezifikation ist komplett offen Encoding- und Decoding-Software
dafür ist offen und das ist jetzt so
ein Nachfolger von, sagen wir mal, VP9 das war früher offener Videostandard
und ist so ein bisschen vergleichbar mit H.265.
Das heißt, das ist das Hauptformat, in dem ihr eure Videos ausliefert,
was Browser auch können müssten ja dann eigentlich?
Ne, es ist eins der Formate. Aber es haben immer wieder mal Leute gefragt,
hey, wann macht ihr denn endlich AV1? Und jetzt machen wir das endlich auch.
Daher habe ich es erwähnt. Und also wir bieten aktuell an H.264,
VP9 und AV1 in fertigen Videoformaten.
Und dann gibt es das ja nicht nur auf media.ccc.de, es gibt ja auch noch einen
YouTube-Kanal, was ich spannend finde, weil YouTube, großer US-amerikanischer
Tech-Konzern, Plattform-Monopolist etc.
Ist die Idee dahinter, ja,
aber wir wollen halt die Inhalte möglichst zugänglich machen und media.ccc.de
ist jetzt sozusagen eine Webseite, die man benutzen kann, aber halt sind die
Leute nicht gewohnt oder wie kam das?
Es gibt zwei Gründe. Zum einen
die sogenannten Smart-TVs, die halt kein Media können.
Und zum anderen, media.ccc.de ist offen.
Da können die Videodateien einfach runtergeladen und abgespeichert werden.
Und wenn es von irgendwas eine Videodatei gibt, dann landet die früher oder
später von irgendwem dann doch auf YouTube.
Im Zweifelsfall allerdings mit falschen Metadaten oder eine veraltete Version,
wo Fehler drin sind oder auch mit dem Maximalen an Werbeeinblendungen,
womit dann wieder Unbeteiligte mit unserem Content Geld verdienen können.
Daher hat das WOC vor einigen Jahren entschieden, wir bespielen YouTube selbst
direkt mit aus unserer Releasing-Pipeline raus.
Und in unserer Releasing-Pipeline sind die ganzen Metadaten,
die richtigen Titel, die richtige Description und alles mögliche andere,
die richtige Lizenz vorhanden.
Da sind wir die Ersten und YouTube meckert dann halt andere an,
die den Reupload versuchen.
Also sozusagen, das war für euch die Wahl zwischen Pest und Cholera und ihr
würdet sozusagen YouTube keiner Tränen hinterherweinen, aber solange die Welt
ist, wie sie ist, ist das die bessere Lösung.
Es gab zeitweise Cholera, als das VOG noch nicht selbst hochgeladen hat.
Da gab es zwei Kanäle, die unsere Videos mit sehr viel Werbung durchsetzt hochgeladen haben.
Die waren dann allerdings glücklicherweise irgendwann Geschichte nachdem sie
versucht haben, ihre alte Schose weiter durchzuziehen, während wir auch schon
mit richtiger Lizenz und meistens schneller hochgeladen haben.
Und das heißt der Kanal vom Vox auch demonetarisiert?
Ja. Wir könnten theoretisch, aber wir machen es nicht.
Ja, das ist das hätte mich auch sehr überrascht, wenn es anders gewesen wäre.
Das muss ich an dieser Stelle schon, ganz ehrlich ich sagen.
Man kann also spontan mitmachen, es gibt aber auch, entnehme ich dem sozusagen
so eine Art festen Kern oder jetzt nicht irgendwie vielleicht eine ganz feste
Gruppe, aber eher auch eine Gruppe von Leuten, die das, weiß ich nicht,
die ganze Zeit machen oder diesen ganzen Vorlaufplan oder sowas.
Wie viele Leute sind das? Wie passiert das?
Also ist das irgendwo geografisch verortet, wenn das alles online stattfindet?
Könnt ihr dir nochmal sozusagen die, was da an der Ecke passiert, ein bisschen erklären?
Es gibt so einen Kern von ich schätze es mal 30 bis 40 Leuten,
die Zugang zu größten Teilen unserer Infrastruktur haben, die dauerhaft läuft,
die Zugang zu unserem Config-Management haben und aus diesem Kreis bilden sich
dann auch immer die WOC-verantwortliche Personen,
also die, die ein Event aus dem Kreis des WOC heraus leitet.
Wie trefft ihr euch? Macht ihr das irgendwie online oder?
Das ist hauptsächlich online, ja.
Ja, also es ist halt Anfang an, besteht das WOG nur online, wir sind über den
gesamten Dach und NL-Raum verteilt.
Es gibt Leute in verschiedensten Städten, die dann die lokalen Events dort fahren.
So, dann habe ich noch eine andere Frage, nämlich,
Jetzt macht ihr das für die chaosnahen Veranstaltungen. Und die Frage kommt
so, die ist so motiviert aus zwei verschiedenen Beobachtungen.
Das eine ist, chaosnahe Veranstaltungen kann man jetzt sozusagen die Gemeinnützigkeit
unterstellen oder das ist halt einfach so.
Und so eine Veranstaltung, die also gute Dinge TM machen, aber kein Geld haben,
aber vielleicht von Videostreaming profitieren können, könnte ich mir vorstellen,
dass die dann fragen, könnt ihr für uns vielleicht auch?
Wie geht ihr mit solchen Anfragen um? Oder ihr sagt jetzt, das passiert gar nicht.
Und das andere ist, ich meine, da könnt ihr mich jetzt auch korrigieren,
aber dass immer mal wieder aus dem Umfeld des Chaos Dinge erwachsen,
die dann auch, ich weiß nicht, ein Produkt oder eine Firma werden.
Also ich glaube zum Beispiel, also ich bin jetzt wirklich nicht tief genug drin,
um das genau zu wissen, dass das Ticketing-System, was im Umfeld des Chaos-Kongress
sozusagen Prätix verwendet wurde in lange Zeit,
das gibt es jetzt auch für den Rest der Welt und das gibt es auch in der Bezahlvariante,
wenn ich es richtig sehe.
Also die kann man sozusagen wirklich buchen, glaube ich so.
Habt ihr sowas auch und wenn ja, wie geht ihr mit sowas um?
Wir nehmen anfragende Events gerne in unseren Eventkalender auf
schauen ob sich Freiwillige finden die das Event übernehmen wollen wenn sich
welche finden lässt sich da meistens drüber reden und eine Lösung finden habt
Ihr da Richtlinien sozusagen welche Events ihr dafür zugangsberechtigt kann man sagen halten.
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir da irgendwas aufgeschrieben haben.
Das ist häufig eine Entscheidung aus dem Bauch und aus dem Team heraus.
Also bloße Vermutung. AfD-Parteitag nein.
Waffenproduzenten-Management-Tagung auch nein.
Ja und tendenziell auch irgendeine Marketingveranstaltung, nein.
Im Endeffekt ist die erste Hürde ja, dass sich jemand, der sich mit der Technik
bereits auskennt, erstmal finden muss, dieses komplette Event zu fahren und
das ist meistens schon ein sehr starker impliziter Filter.
Ich glaube die AfD, da braucht man nicht drüber reden, da hat der CCC eine eindeutige
Positionierung insofern.
Aber das heißt sozusagen, dieses gefühlte Ding von, wenn es Nerdkram ist oder keine Ahnung,
Bildungsveranstaltungen chronisch unterfinanziert zu sagen, dann probably eher
ja, wenn sich jemand findet, aber wenn irgendwie Big Money dahinter steckt und
jemand versucht quasi sein Budget zu sparen, obwohl er es eigentlich hätte, dann eher nein.
Genau, also das ist auch die Idee, dass wenn du jetzt kleine Veranstaltungen
hast, wo du gerade mal eben drei Entwickler oder vielleicht ein paar mehr zu
einem Entwicklertreffen, wo auch Vorträge gehalten werden,
hast organisieren können, vielleicht einen kleinen Raum, geht zwei Tage und
du möchtest das gerne irgendwie veröffentlicht sehen.
Das ist so die Art von Veranstaltung, wo wir sagen, jawohl, da sind wir gerne
dabei, immer unter dem Vorzeichen, dass sich jemand findet, der das dann auch vor Ort fährt.
Aber das ist so eine ganz klassische Nummer, die wir auch bedienen.
Ich glaube, was man auch dazu sagen muss, ist es halt immer dann auch eine Sache,
wo die Talks nachher öffentlich verfügbar sind für alle.
Und nicht jetzt dann hinter einer Paywall verschwinden.
Okay, verstehe. Um das zu erklären, das gibt es auch als Modell.
Also es gibt zum Beispiel die, ich weiß nicht, das ist so ein bisschen wie Volksfonds
und die Idee, auch die ideische Volksfonds. Es gibt die Games Developer Konferenz, glaube ich.
Und die haben als Geschäftsmodell, das ist eine riesige Veranstaltung,
die Tickets auch teuer. Und da gibt es aber auch keinen Online-Zugang zu den Vorträgen.
Also es gibt es sozusagen als Konferenz-Business-Modell das so zu machen,
aber ihr sagt halt, vielleicht ja, aber Grundvoraussetzung ist,
alles, was da produziert wird, ist öffentlich für alle ohne Geld zugänglich.
So, und dann noch die andere Sache sozusagen. Manchmal ergibt sich ja dann sozusagen
so, dass man halt vielleicht aus dem Wissen, dass man sich da arbeitet,
vielleicht, weil die Leute gut zusammen funktionieren, dann auch so eine Art,
Business Opportunity klingt halt jetzt mega schmierig, aber vielleicht sagen
ja Leute irgendwann, hey, ihr seid das WOC und ich weiß, das WOC ist für bestimmte
Dinge da, was wir eindeutig nicht sind, sondern wir wollen das kaufen. Gibt es sowas auch?
Ich bin eigentlich nur, passiert sowas?
Das Einzige, was wir mal gemacht haben, sind zwei Dinge.
Die eine kann Sophie, glaube ich, gerade besser erzählen. Das andere,
was wir gemacht haben, ist, das OpenSUSE-Projekt hat sich zum Beispiel mal von
uns inspirieren lassen und dann haben wir denen quasi erklärt,
was sie brauchen, um sich so ein Flightcase zusammenzustellen.
Und als sie das dann gehört haben, haben sie gesagt, ja, das klingt ja alles
ganz nett, aber könnt ihr uns vielleicht dabei unterstützen, das zu bauen.
Und dann haben wir das mehr oder weniger für die gebaut.
Aber das ist jetzt nichts, was wir als Dienstleistung in dem Sinne anbieten
würden, im größeren Scale.
Das würde ich jetzt mal so als One-Off bezeichnen. Das kann jeder gerne für
sich machen, aber das war schon...
Schon eher aufwendig. Und das ist aber dann auch eher so klassisches Open-Source-Community
möchte gerne selber Dinge aufnehmen können.
Und Sophie?
Es gibt ein paar Events, die inzwischen
auch quasi feste Plätze in unserer Veranstaltungskalender haben,
die eigentlich Open-Source in ihrem Namen haben, die durchaus aber auch ein
bisschen in Richtung Business gehen und eine große Liste an Sponsoren haben,
die mieten sich unsere Technik und Dienstleistungen und bezahlendem Personal
in Anführungsstrichle, also unsere
Freiwilligen, die da zu dem Event fahren, auch die Anfahrt und die Unterkunft
und unterstützen so auch das WOC.
Denn, du wolltest glaube ich auch noch gerade?
Genau, und wenn irgendwie im WOC Leuten so ein bisschen ihr normaler Alltagsjob
raushängt, dann gibt es doch immer wieder den Running Gag, lass uns doch die WOC Gäste in BH gründen.
Aber das ist mehr ein Running Gag als ernst.
Also am Ende muss man dann wieder mit den normalen Eventdienstleistern konkurrieren
und das ist dann halt auch nochmal, also das wäre sicher drin,
aber dafür fühlen wir uns im Schnitt dann doch immer wieder in unseren Alltagsjobs zu wohl.
Okay, das wäre dann quasi Hobby zum Beruf machen und das ist ja mein zweischneidiges Schwert.
Genau das.
Okay. Ich will noch auf jeden Fall will ich noch zwei Sachen machen.
Das eine ist, es gibt so ein Vorbereitungspad, da habt ihr sozusagen was an
Funfacts und Anekdoten könnte man vielleicht erzählen und ich will eines davon sozusagen nachfragen.
Weil ich total toll finde, dass egal in welchen Fachbereich man geht,
es entwickelt sich immer sofort so eine eigene Sprache.
Also es gibt immer so eine Fachlingo, wo man als Außenstehender denkt, hä?
Und zum Beispiel steht da der schöne Satz, Audinate, Dante hat nach dem Kongress
neue Firmware released mit Fixes für die Brocklin 2 im Behringer Wingen.
Alles klar, was zur Hölle bedeutet das?
Also, ja, da kann ich mal ausholen.
Ja, bitte.
Also, Dante ist ein Protokoll für Audio über IP-Übertragung in Echtzeit.
Das ist intern sehr, sehr ähnlich zu dem offenen Standard IS67.
Aber die waren so einen der ersten, die quasi über Ethernet Audio übertragen
haben, zwischen quasi vorne der Bühne und Mischpult und alles dazwischen.
In Echtzeit quasi mit Latencies so um eine Millisekunde rum.
Also total braucht man für einen Livebetrieb.
Nur als kleiner Vergleich, wir nehmen gerade über der Studiolink VoIP-Software
auf und ich habe die Verzögerung 100 Millisekunden eingestellt,
damit es keine Aussetzer gibt.
Netzwerkkabel ist dann Faktor 100, okay?
Genau, aber selbst das ist halt schwierig. Also so Audio mit der Latency über
Netzwerkübertragung ist schwierig und da braucht es einiges in Technik dafür.
Und die waren eines der Ersten, die das gemacht haben. Und dadurch sind sie
so ein bisschen ein Platzhirsch, der halt immer noch im professionellen Audiobereich sehr verbreitet ist.
Und beim Kongress nutzen wir das
und halt auch das Gebäude selber für ihre Haustechnik nutzt das überall.
Und wir haben dadurch halt Audio durchs ganze Gebäude geschoben.
Und wir hatten da so ein Problem, dass wir immer wieder Klicks hatten im Audio. und
Das einerseits in unserem Büro, wo wir quasi gemonitored haben,
aber auch in den Streams.
Am Schluss hat sich herausgestellt, dass beides zwei komplett unterschiedliche Gründe hat.
Nämlich, wie wir sowas im Büro gehört haben, war tatsächlich ein Bug in diesem Modul.
Und zwar so wie Dante funktioniert, ist das, dass Dante verkauft quasi fertige System-on-a-Modules.
Das ist quasi ein Board, wo halt eine CPU oder FPGA drauf ist und RAM und alles
fertig ist. dass man quasi nur wo reinsteckt, um eine Funktion zu kriegen.
Das Audinate ist der Hersteller von diesem Dante. Ah, okay. Genau,
und die verkaufen ein Modul für Mischpult-Hersteller, das heißt Brooklyn 2.
Und wir hatten dort einen Behringer Wing, das ist ein digitales Audion-Mischpult
stehen, und das hat eine Dante-Karte drin gehabt.
Und diese Dante-Karte, die man da reinbauen kann, die verwendet dieses Brooklyn 2-Modul.
Und wir hatten halt dort auch Klicks immer wieder gehört. und irgendwann haben
wir herausgefunden, dass das nur auf dem Wing diese Klicks zum Hören sind.
Das war aber nicht bei uns im Recording-Path drin, das war unser Monitoring-Tool.
Das heißt, da haben wir nur halt in die einzelnen Streams reinhorchen können mit.
Und danach gab es halt ein Bug-Report von einer Person im Team von uns,
von Toonfish, an Audinate und Behringer.
Und dann auf einmal, so drei Monate nach dem Kongress, liest man,
es gibt ein neues Firmware-Release, der genau diesen Bug behoben hat,
dass diese Klicks zu hören waren.
Genau, aber wieso beim Kongress gab es halt noch diese ganze andere Geschichte,
wo wir auch Klicks in den Aufnahmen hatten, die war aber hat eine ganz andere
Sache gehabt und vielleicht, ich weiß ja nicht, ob wer von euch beiden da mehr
dazu erzählen kann Daniel und Sophie
Wir haben am Kongress nicht nur den Originalton, der auf der Bühne produziert
und gesprochen wird, also die Originalsprache sondern auch bis zu zwei Übersetzer-Spuren,
also Live-Translation, simultanen Übersetzer.
Und da die Kameras, die wir haben, nur zwei Audio-Eingänge haben,
die für den Originalton benutzt werden, braucht es irgendwo noch eine Möglichkeit,
weitere Audio-Kanäle mit in das SDI und mit in unsere Aufnahmerechner zu füttern.
Dafür haben wir auf dem Kongress zum ersten Mal im größeren Ausbau Audio-Embedder benutzt, die AES 3,
ein digitaler Audio-Standard auf einem XLR-Kabel annehmen und das in das STI-Signal embedden.
Nur kurz nach Fragen. Also das ist eine Technik, die erlaubt,
dass in dem Videosignal das wir verwenden, dann gleich mehrere Audio-Streams mit drin sind.
Genau, genau. Das IS-3 ist, ich peile jetzt noch mehr Fachwärter mit drauf auf den Stapel.
Das IS-3 fällt aus der Stagebox hinter der Bühne.
Da hatten wir uns gedacht, da ist doch auch direkt nebendran der Mischer für
das Bild, was auf der Leinwand auftaucht, die Slides.
Also können wir einfach das IS-3 in das Slide-Signal embedden und damit zum
Encoding-Rechner schicken.
Hat sich hinterher als Problem herausgestellt, weil irgendwas in diesem Slide-Signal
oder in dem IS-3-Signal diese Audio-Embedder verwirrt hat, dass sie nach einer
Weile es klicken haben angefangen.
Ich frage mich wirklich halt genau die Kombination zwischen diesem Presentation-Switch,
was Sophie erwähnt hat, dem Audio-Embedder und der SDI-Karte-NPC.
Wirklich nur genau diese eine Kombination hat der Fehler verursacht.
Es hat leider drei Tage gebraucht, bis wir das Problem gefunden hatten.
Also drei Kongresstage, während die Vorträge schon liefen.
Inzwischen sind aber alle Aufnahmen aus sauberen Backups repariert auf mediaccc.de.
Genau das. Falls ihr euch gewundert habt, warum die Releases so lange gedauert
haben, dieses Mal speziell auf YouTube. bei YouTube kann man nicht re-releasen
im Gegensatz zu media.ccc.de zumindest nicht unter der gleichen URL
Und deswegen hat das dann bei YouTube gedauert, bis wir sauberes Audio überall
hatten, bis es dann geleased wurde und das hat dann teilweise einen Monat gedauert.
Das ist übrigens auch genau die Sache, wir haben einen Monat gebraucht,
um diese Videos von Hand zu streicheln, was wir sonst einfach während des Events
machen und das ist auch der Grund, warum
wir das eigentlich nur über diese vollautomatisierte Pipeline tun können.
Wir kriegen den Fahrplan und mit den Metadaten, die da drin stehen,
automatisieren wir quasi alles, was wir haben.
Und wir haben ein Ablauftool, den Tracker, der quasi mitkriegt,
jetzt kommen Daten rein, weil der Talk gerade läuft.
Jetzt ist der Talk zu Ende, jetzt kann der Talk geschnitten werden.
Jetzt wird der Talk encoded in Format A, B, C.
Jetzt wird der hochgeladen zu media.ccc.de, zu YouTube, möglicherweise auch
noch zu Drittplattformen. Das sind alles so Dinge, die nur funktionieren,
weil wir Metadaten haben.
Das sind auch so Dinge, die wir im Vorfeld immer klären.
Hat diese Konferenz ein ordentliches Planungstool, gibt auch Konferenzen oder
gerade so Sachen, die jetzt nicht primär ihren Fokus auf Vorträge legen,
die schieben uns dann irgendwie so ein Excel-Sheet mit Vorträgen zu.
Das heißt, da gibt es dann so diverse kleine Tools, die mal geschrieben wurden,
um daraus einen entsprechenden Schedule zu bauen in diesem Standardformat.
Und nur deswegen können wir diese Dinge so schnell und in Echtzeit tun, wie wir sie tun.
Das klingt alles sehr aufregend und auch alles sehr aufwendig und sehr viel.
Ich würde jetzt eigentlich nochmal zurückblicken wollen und fragen wollen,
manche sozusagen solche Unternehmungen oder manche solche Arbeitsgruppen haben
ja einen Erweckungs- oder sozusagen Entstehungsmoment.
Gibt es sozusagen einen Mythos, in welcher konkreten Situation das WOC entstanden
ist oder ist das eher so ein Ding gewesen von, man hat festgestellt,
dass man eigentlich schon sehr lange an Dingen arbeitet und lass uns doch mal
vielleicht das irgendwie mit drei Buchstaben abkürzen.
Auf dem Kongress gab es schon immer sehr viele Versuche, diese Vorträge mitzuschneiden.
Es gab die Femme, die das konsequent gemacht hat. Die waren halt zum Ende immer weniger Menschen.
Dann gab es so Einzelinitiativen von Leuten, die dann so ganz kleine DV-Kameras
aufgestellt haben, so diese, die man sonst immer in Urlaub mitnimmt.
Und im Endeffekt stellte sich dann raus, die FEMM hat das zwar sehr gut gemacht,
aber immer weniger geworden personell.
Wir selber hatten das halt gesehen, dass wir das immer häufiger brauchten.
Auf so Veranstaltungen wie der Frostcon haben wir uns dann so Dienstleister geholt,
die das dann vor Ort mitgeschnitten haben, aber wir haben im Grunde nie oder
mit sehr, sehr viel Verspätung erst diese Videos bekommen, was eigentlich ein
bisschen interessant ist, wenn man sich doch kommerzielle Dienstleister holt.
Deren Job das ja genau ist.
Aber das ist dann, du nimmst das auf als Dienstleister und dann musst du das
halt irgendeine armer Studie schneiden. Und das wurde mir so erzählt.
Und das passiert dann mit sehr, sehr viel Verzögerung.
Und wir haben uns halt überlegt, wie können wir das machen, dass wir selber
dazu in der Lage sind, als CCC unsere und befreundete Events aufzuzeichnen.
Und daraus entstand dann iterativ das VOG. Das heißt, wir haben nicht von Anfang
an diese Flight Cases besorgt, sondern wir haben erstmal Hardware geliehen.
Wir haben auch mit der FEM gesprochen.
Die FEM und andere uninaren Vereine sind uns da auch immer noch sehr zugetan.
Das ist also kein Wir gegen die, sondern wir haben da, glaube ich,
eine sehr gute Symbiose geschafft.
Und so sind wir in eine Situation gekommen, wo wir uns dann professionalisiert
haben, erstmal diese vier Flight Cases geplant haben, haben festgestellt,
mit vier Flight Cases schaffen wir zwar die meisten Veranstaltungen,
aber nicht sowas wie den Kongress und schon gar nicht Veranstaltungen,
die möglicherweise parallel laufen.
Dann haben wir nochmal zwei Cases angeschafft und jetzt mit diesen sechs Cases
sind wir, denke ich, ganz gut aufgestellt und diese sechs Cases wiederum,
die haben dann immer mehr Huckepack-Kisten bekommen und diese alten Cases plus
Huckepack-Kisten werden jetzt ersetzt durch jeweils zwei Cases pro Raum in diesem VOG 2.0 Setup.
Das heißt, es hat sich alles iterativ entwickelt und ich glaube,
dass das Erste, was dann tatsächlich gefahren wurde mit geliehener Hardware,
war ein Camp und das Erste, was gefahren wurde mit einem eigenen Setup.
Es gab mal vor grauer Zeit in Köln eine Veranstaltung,
die so ein bisschen ausgelegt war wie der Kongress und das hat aber nur zweimal
stattgefunden und dafür hatten wir dann das erste Mal, wenn ich das richtig entsinne,
unser eigenes Setup am Start und dann für die Frostkorn auch.
Danimo hat jetzt Geschichte von den letzten 15 Jahren kurz zusammengefasst.
Das war schon eine Weile unterwegs.
Okay, jetzt haben wir ja sozusagen zwei Dinge gelernt, also hinter die Kulissen
des Kongresses und anderer Veranstaltungen, hinter die Kulissen des TCC,
weil die Art und Weise, wie sich das entwickelt und organisiert hat,
ist halt sozusagen jetzt,
ich weiß nicht, ob prototypisches, richtige Wort ist, aber sozusagen kommt Kennern
und Kennerinnen der Materie wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht so neu vor.
Und ich habe am Anfang aber vollmordlich versprochen, es hat auch was mit dem
Chaos Radio zu tun, dann Nimo.
Genau, wir haben als VOG eine ganze Weile auch das Chaos Radio gestreamt.
Das war ganz spannend, weil wir haben das Chaos Radio ja lange Zeit bei Fritz
im Studio gemacht und später halt auch im Club alle zwei Monate,
aber du kennst das, wenn man einen Hammer hat, dann ist alles ein Nagel und ich war halt…
Und ich war halt beim Bock und dachte mir so, ja, also dieses Chaosradio ist
ja irgendwie so ein bisschen unbefriedigend, dass man den Leuten nur über die Webcam zugucken kann.
Lass das doch mal in ordentlich machen. Und wir haben uns dann irgendwann Kameras
gekauft, die auch direkt auf IP streamen konnten.
Und eine dieser Kameras hat der Berliner Club gekauft, der auch das Chaos Radio hier veranstaltet.
Und diese Kamera ist dann einfach immer mitgefahren. Zusammen mit einem Stativ
sind wir dann da reingelaufen, an einem etwas verwunderten Förtner vorbei und
haben uns dann da in das Rack eingesteckt,
eine ominöse Klappe im Studio-Doppelboden geöffnet,
ein Kabel rausgeangelt, was mit Chaos-Radio beschriftet war.
Und das war das einzige Kabel, glaube ich, beim RBB, wo dreckiges Internet rauskommt,
ohne dass irgendjemand schreit.
Und darüber haben wir dann gestreamt.
Und dann gab es auf MediaCCC.de zeitgleich zum Radiobroadcast das Chaos Radio mit Bildspur.
Genau, das hat sich dann aber irgendwann auch wieder eingestellt,
weil wir irgendwann aufgehört haben, live zu senden und vielleicht braucht nicht
alles ein Bewegtbild, auch wenn das als Vogue wahrscheinlich schwer zu hören ist.
Ich muss gestehen, eine vernünftige Postproduktion hat auch seine Vorzüge.
Okay, ich finde, ich habe jetzt einen sehr schönen Einblick bekommen und ich
hoffe, ihr liebe HörerInnen auch,
dass sozusagen, was das WOC ist, was es kann, was es macht und vor allen Dingen
auch wie viel Aufwand dahinter ist, dass ihr vom Kongress und anderen Veranstaltungen
einfach sozusagen einen schönen Livestream und auch danach die Videos sehen könnt.
Bevor ich aber alles zu mache, habt ihr noch was, was ihr dringend loswerden wollt?
Kommt vorbei und engelt.
Okay, Sophie sagt, kommt vorbei und engelt. Danny?
Ich habe es vorhin einmal schon kurz erwähnt, aber weil es immer wieder Leute
überrascht sind, wenn ich das erzähle, wenn ihr die Videos von uns auf mediasitz.de
guckt und runterlädt, dann sind da zwei Videospuren in dieser Datei.
Wenn ihr was benutzt wie VLC oder MPV, könnt ihr auch zwischen denen hin und
her schalten oder beide gleichzeitig anzeigen. und in dieser zweiten Videospur
sieht man die Slides die ganze Zeit.
Das heißt, wenn es mal passiert, dass irgendwo ein Engel zu spät auf eine Slide
umschaltet oder die ganz vergisst, dann sieht man in dieser zweiten Videospur
diese Slides und kann die sich anschauen.
Das geht halt auf YouTube nicht, weil das kann keine zwei Videospuren,
deswegen nutzt MediaCCCD.
Alles klar, weil ihr jetzt ab und zu über das Case 2.0 geredet habt.
Ihr habt dazu gerade auch einen Vortrag gehalten und von dem gibt es,
Achtung, eine Aufzeichnung. und diese Aufzeichnung verlinken wir auch in den Shownotes.
Falls ihr euch da sozusagen schon mal im Detail dafür interessiert,
was da jetzt drin steckt in diesem Case 2.0, dann lässt ihr das auch noch erfahren.
Vielen lieben Dank, auf jeden Fall Jenny, Sophie und Animo, dass ihr heute hier
wart und ein bisschen davon erzählt habt, wie so ein Video Operation Center
funktioniert, was eigentlich eine ganz spannende Geschichte ist.
Und ihr, liebe HörerInnen, habt es gehört.
Falls ihr euch dafür interessiert, keine Angst, das Ding ist offen.
Man kann halt sozusagen gucken, wo man hin will, der Kalender,
welche Themen verlinken wir auch. Also guckt einfach in die Shownotes,
wenn euch das Thema interessiert und ihr noch mehr wissen wollt.
Und ansonsten bleibt mir wie immer nur noch eine Sache zu sagen.
Wenn ihr nicht auf der Bühne steht, lasst euch nicht überwachen.
Quatsch. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups. Tschüss.